herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute sind wieder mit dem ball am start
guck mal hier ich habe ihm schon mal zum
test gefragt wurde zog wars krankhafter
und das hier ist dabei rausgekommen
sieht eigentlich ganz nett sein letzter
alle prüfen gehabt man ist jetzt schon
direkt am start korrekt von ihm sagt
jemand man sieht hier ganz gut wieder
jobs denn jeder wird seine arbeit war
somit die doppel ausbau die berühmte ich
bin als augenbrauen am start die an
mcdonald's nämlich an mcdonald's bei
wenn ihr mich nicht so nennt dann warum
warum lebt wir dann eigentlich noch das
bild ist jetzt nicht nicht verstörend
ist schon ein bisschen verstehen aber es
ist noch nicht so schrecklich wie
teilweise die anderen bilder werden
wurde der sketch up the fucking
prostituierte in die knie zwingen
leute juni-dax kattowitz confirmed
unterscheiden sich gar nicht
ich weiß ja nicht aber das jetzt macht
aber fakt in die erst kann ich glaub ich
jeder erklären und donkey ist bitter
das macht dann springe ich genau jetzt
aus dem fenster und der macht nichts
mehr voran
ja
ich wurde was abgeht was ihn stoppen er
aus versehen seine freundin zahn
ausgeschlagen und wir waren bei
derselben party und das waren wir so
lustig das war glaube ich letzten
freitag oder so um die letzten freitag
in köln auf irgendeiner youtube partie
und da war halt neben luca auch noch
marcel scorpion und irgendwann marcel
als osama youtube video gesagt was
abbekommt ist wohl die geschichte
erzählt habe ich euch aber die
beschreibung gepackt auf jeden fall
die story ist er war hat besoffen und
ist abgehauen und irgendwann so 2 stand
nach dem abgang ist um ein uhr nachts
kam so die nachricht so jungs jungs
marcel hat seiner freundin zahn
ausgeschlagen und meinen so dinger da
kommt bestimmt
und gestern maximal software zeige ich
dir so etwas war gab beim joggen komme
nach hause machten ihr liebling auf
meiner freundin zu schlagen
marcel ist eigentlich ganz gut warum
warum gibt's wars domestic future also
die mäßige users häusliche gewalt der
mäßig weilands darum gibts sowas darum
warum kann er mehr features machen
wie wäre es denn mit von crafter was
wäre wenn blut also konkreter mülleimer
warum brennt die klasse die genügend
verschwörung aufgedeckt auf seine backe
steht aber so amy ohne witz dieser lose
gesichert
eine windmühle leute natürlich
das ist glaube ich von lukas bildet kann
es sei immer irgendwer von lugo ein jahr
auf seinem gesicht steht erste frage
warum hat ein bad
eine zweite frage warum ist er nicht in
der windmühle drin
eine wichtige frage noch klären müssen
allesamt früher zuschauer sorgten die
kommentare geschrieben wo ab fsk sorgt
wars tadel maxi zahlen geschrieben
okay sind nicht wirklich menschlich aus
aber bot genug picture es ist leider
immer noch nicht menschlich damit können
wir arbeiten sollte einfach mal so
ausgewählt auf instagram posten hier
helfen ja schreibt
okay wir machen wenn das video 7000
likes erreicht verspreche ich kopiere
ich dieses bild hier genau dieses bild
ich speichers jetzt und postet auf
instagram auf meinem öffentlichen
instagram account und lass es da für
mindestens zwei wochen alter job